We're on test 8, section
5, page 855.
Problem 1.
If x over x minus 2 is
equal to 39 over 37,
then what does x equal?
And here you could try to solve
this situation, but
there's just a pattern here
that you could actually
identify immediately.
If x is 39, then what
is x minus 2?
x minus 2's going to be 37.
So you could immediately just
try out these numbers.
That just kind of struck
you because 37 is
two less than 39.
x minus 2 is 2 less than x.
So x must be 39.
You could do that problem
really fast.
If you don't understand what I'm
saying you could kind of
solve it with the traditional
method, cross multiply.
You could say 37 times
x, 37x is equal to 39
times x minus 2.
So you get 37x is equal to 39x
minus, what is that, minus 78.
And then you could subtract 39x
from both sides and you
get minus 2x is equal
to minus 78.
Divide both sides by 2 and
you get x is equal to 39.
But that would have taken
a lot of valuable time.
The first problem with any
section on the SAT, if you
can't do it in 10 seconds
you might be doing
it the wrong way.
It's normally a very,
very quick problem.
And that's why this probably
was not the correct
way of doing it.
You could have just said well
if x is 39, x minus 2 is 37.
Next problem.
Problem 2.
Students in advanced biology
class-- so they have boys,
girls, total.
And then on this side,
this juniors,
seniors, and then total.
And then they write-- this is
k, n, m, r, s, t, w, x, z.
In the table above, each letter
represents the number
of students in that category.
k would be the number of junior
boys in the advanced
biology class.
Which of the following
must be equal to z?
So z is the total number
of kids, right?
So there's a couple of things
that could be equal to z.
It could be w plus x.
That's not a choice.
It could also be m plus t.
But that's not a choice
either, right, m
plus t isn't a choice.
And the other way is you could
just add up all of the kids
that are in each of
the categories.
So z is the total
of all the kids.
So if you say the number of
junior boys plus senior boys
plus junior girls plus senior
girls, so that's k plus
n plus r plus s.
That's all the students
in the class, right?
And that must equal z.
And that is choice E.
Next problem.
They have a line
here like that.
And then what do they tell us?
They tell us that this right
here is 25 degrees.
This is a, b, c, this is 60
degrees, and this is x.
In the triangle ABC above,
what is the value of x.
This is just the angle game.
So the first thing we want to
figure out is this angle.
And we know that this angle plus
60 is going to be 180,
right, because it's
supplementary.
They kind of combined to form
180 degrees, or they kind of
created a line to go halfway
around the circle.
So this has to be 120.
Because this plus 60 is 180.
And then we see that 25 plus
120 plus x have to be 180
because they're all in
the same triangle.
So 25 plus 120 plus x is going
to be equal to 180 as well.
So 145 plus x is equal to 180.
Subtract 145 from both sides.
You get x is equal to 35.
80 minus 45.
Right.
35 and that's choice C.
Next problem.
Problem 4.
The Martin's refrigerator
is broken and will
cost $300 to fix.
And new energy efficient
refrigerator costing $900, so
let's say this other
refrigerator costs $900.
It'll save 15 dollars a month
on the electric bill.
If they buy the new refrigerator
in x months, the
Martin's will have saved an
amount equal to the difference
between the cost of the new
refrigerator and the cost of
the old one.
What is the value of x?
So they're saying that in x
months this new refrigerator--
they're saying if in x months
the Martin's would have saved
an amount equal to the
difference between the cost of
the new refrigerator and the
cost of fixing the old one.
So what's the cost of the
new refrigerator?
It's $900.
And what's the cost of
fixing the old one?
It's $300.
So that's the difference between
the cost of fixing the
new refrigerator and the cost
of fixing the old one.
And they say that that's
how much they will
have saved in x months.
So they're going to save
that in x months.
They save $15 a month, right?
So $15 times x months has to be
equal to the difference in
price, essentially, of
fixing or buying.
And this is a times,
not a minus.
So you get $600 is
equal to 15x.
So x is equal to 600 over 15.
So x is equal to 40-- 15 goes in
60 four times, it goes into
600 40 times.
So that's choice D.
It takes 40 months for
them to break even.
Next problem.
Problem 5.
The perimeter of an equilateral
triangle ABC is 3
times the perimeter of an
equilateral triangle DEF.
Let me draw them real fast. This
is one of them, and the
other one actually is smaller.
If I called this one ABC,
this one is DEF.
They say the perimeter of this
one is 3 times this one-- and
they're both equilateral, right,
so this is x, x, x.
And so we don't know what
these sides are.
But the perimeter of this
one will be 3x-- oh,
then they tell us.
If the perimeter of DEF is
10, what is the length
of one side of ABC?
So perimeter of triangle
DEF is equal to 10.
And they tell us that
the perimeter of
ABC is 3 times this.
So that means that the perimeter
of triangle ABC is
going to be 3 times this,
so it's 30, right?
So the perimeter of this
triangle is 30 and it's three
equal sides, so each
side has to be 10.
30 divided by 3.
And that's choice B.
Next problem.
Problem 6.
A machine mints coins at the
rate of one coin per second.
If it does this for 10 hours
each day, approximately how
many days will it take the
machine to mint 360,000 coins?
How many days?
So let's say how much does
it produce in one day?
So let's see, in one day is
equal to-- so it'll be
producing for 10 hours
per day times how
many seconds per hour?
Times 3,600 seconds per hour.
And how did I get 3,600?
60 minutes per hour times 60
seconds per minute, right,
that gives you 3,600 times
one coin per second.
And the units actually
cancel out.
The hours cancel out with
hours, and then you get
seconds cancel out with seconds,
and you're left with
coins per day.
So that equals 10 times 3,600
is 36, 1, 2, add another 0,
3,600 coins per day.
So the amount of coins I produce
in d days is going to
be 3,600 times d, times
the number of days.
And that we're saying has
to be equal to 360,000.
Well immediately let's divide
both sides-- d will be 360,000
divided by 3,600.
So that's cancels
out with that.
You have 360 divided by 36, well
that's just equal to 10.
So it will take 10 days to
produce 360,000 coins, and
that's choice A.
I'll see you in the
next video.